now we've been battling this pandemic
for the better part of a year
more than 450 000 americans have lives
have been taken
we've been separated from our friends
and family
thousands of schools and businesses have
been sitting empty
and americans have had their lives
turned upside down by the pandemic
meanwhile millions of americans
are doing everything in their power to
put the country and the world
back on the right course millions of you
are wearing masks
and the evidence dr wolenski has
discussed here demonstrates
that in communities where that happens
lives are being saved
that needs to continue and improve in
the face of the threats we confront
we know that millions of americans are
also waiting patiently to be vaccinated
today i want to begin the briefing by
updating you on what is happening
while you're waiting in the weeks
and even months that you are waiting the
nation's efforts
are being spent focused on many who are
most at risk of hospitalization and
death
from this virus the elderly seniors
frontline healthcare workers and many
essential workers
according to a recent cdc report the
long-term care program
has administered now over 4.8 million
doses
to more than 3.7 million of our most
vulnerable
those who were dying in large numbers
over the last year
are now on a path to protection
and in skilled nursing facilities that
have had at least one
vaccination clinic an estimated median
of almost 80 percent of residents
have received at least one dose of
vaccine
as vaccinations at these facilities are
completed
that will mean more lot many more lives
saved
many more vaccines that can be moved
into the inventory
for the next priority groups and in
total
of the over 40 million doses that have
been administered
over 17 million doses have been
administered
to people 65 or older
now this is a great representation
of the american spirit of generosity and
american selflessness
because our ability to vaccinate
millions of the elderly
seniors and healthcare workers is a
testament to a society
that has put our parents and
grandparents those who have served us
those who continue to sacrifice for us
on the front lines of health care system
first now at the same time
we need to step up efforts to increase
vaccinations of racial and ethnic
communities
that have suffered disproportionately
health equity
is a cornerstone of all of our work and
we'll be talking more about progress
there in upcoming briefings
even with that perspective and progress
we understand that the process moves
more slowly than anyone would like
but each day we are putting forth
efforts
to increase vaccine supply including by
use of the defense production act
to create more places to get vaccinated
including
new large community vaccination centers
and retail pharmacies
and mobilize more vaccinators by
allowing retired physicians and nurses
in deploying the military
this is a national emergency and the
approach we are taking reflects this
we are putting every resource and tool
that the federal government has into
this battle
and we're taking a hold of government
indeed a whole of country approach
as soon as the congress puts the
american rescue plan on the president's
desk
we will be able to further increase this
effort
we understand this is a long journey but
thanks to the sacrifice of so many of
you
in the step-by-step plan we are
executing
for many of our most vulnerable
americans the risk of death
is being reduced and we are committed to
leaving no stone unturned
with that i'll turn it over to dr
walensky for a state of the pandemic
update
and dr frauchi for the latest science
before we answer your questions dr
olensky
thank you so much andy i'm so glad to be
back and joining you today
today i'm going to give you a brief
update on the pandemic
as i mentioned on friday despite trends
moving in the right direction
we remain in a very serious situation
kova 19
continues to affect too many people as
we continue to mourn
all of those lives that have been lost
cases have continued to decline over the
last four weeks
an average of 119 900 new cases were
reported between january 31st
and february 6. that's a drop of nearly
20
from the prior week but still
dramatically higher than the last
summer's peak
we must continue to drive these cases
down
new coven 19 hospital admissions also
continued to decline
an average of 9977 mission admissions
per day were reported between january
30th
and february 5th a decline of nearly 17
from the week prior this is promising
but hospitalizations
also remain incredibly high over 83
000 americans are hospitalized right now
with covid19
much higher than the summer and fall
today
we are reporting that covet 19 deaths
increased
2.4 percent to an average of 3 221
deaths per day
from january 31st to february 6.
as i mentioned on friday sometimes
delays in reporting can lead to
fluctuations in the data
this is the case for the average number
of deaths reported today
which includes a delayed report of 1570
confirmed deaths from one state these
deaths were reported last week
but actually had occurred over the prior
several months
we may continue to see the variation in
daily deaths for different reasons
including reporting delays we are
continuing to watch these data closely
and although hospital admissions and
cases consistently are consistently
dropping
i'm asking everyone to please keep
your guard up the continued
proliferation of variants remains of
great concern
and is a threat that could reverse the
recent positive trends we are seeing
as of february 7th 699 variant cases
have been confirmed
across 34 states with 690 of these cases
being the b117 variant
the variant first reported in the uk
please continue to wear a mask and stay
at six feet apart from people you don't
live with
avoid travels crowds and poorly
ventilated spaces
and get vaccinated when it's available
to you
i recognize that the pandemic has taken
an enormous toll on all of us
but if we all work together and take
these prevention steps
we can finally turn the tide thank you i
look forward to your questions and i
will now turn things over to dr fauci
dr patchy thank you very much dr
valencia i'd like to address
briefly two issues that have come up for
discussion
over the last several days and one is
the question
of given the fact that there is a
greater
demand than there is supply should we be
putting
all of our effort into getting the first
dose into people with less emphasis
on the second dose now the reason for
that
i have explained in the past because the
science has shown
in the both of the vaccines that we have
currently available the moderna
and the pfizer the strong data indicates
that a prime boost gives a maximum
response
of 94 to 95 efficacy but the question
has arisen
why not study in detail whether or not
you can get away with a single
dose it is not an unreasonable thing to
suggest
a study the only issue is that the
practicality of that
really makes that a situation that i
don't think is able to be done for the
following reason
if you look at the number of people that
would be required
in a study to answer that question again
one versus two with the currently
available vaccines
the time it took to get information on
the phase three and the number of people
that that study with all due respect
would take several months to get a
meaningful answer
at that time the amount of vaccine that
would be available
would almost be making that question
somewhat
of a moot point so then let's ask
ourselves
the question is what do we do know about
one dose
versus two dose and the data i think are
important
to present we know from the original
studies that following a single dose
of either the modena or the pfizer you
had a response that gave you a
neutralizing antibody above the
threshold of protection
so it did give some degree of protection
and the question was it was protection
clearly
against the wild type however the boost
either 21 or 28 days later
was 10 fold higher so it went for
example from
one to a hundred to well over one to a
thousand
in the tighter the reason that's
important not only because of the height
of the response and the potency of the
response
but as you get to that level of antibody
you get a
greater breadth of response and by
breadth of response
we mean it covers not only the wild type
and currently circulating virus but also
the variants
that we see circulating particularly the
one
one seven and the three five ones so
it's not just a matter of potency it's a
matter of
the breadth of what you can cover the
other
theoretical issue that could be
problematic with regard to only a single
dose
that if you get a sub response
the way viruses respond to pressure
you could actually be inadvertently
selecting
for more mutants by a sub-optimum
response so for that reason
we have continued to go by the fact that
we feel the optimum approach would be
to continue with getting as many people
on their first dose as possible but also
making sure
that people on time get their second
dose and finally one thing i want to
emphasize
as we know and we've heard and it's true
that the projection is that the 117
lineage would likely become dominant in
the united states
by the end of march please remember that
the efficacy
of the currently utilized vaccines the
two mrna
are quite effective against the 117
lineage so underscoring what dr wilinski
just said
the two things that we can do is a
make sure we adhere to the public health
measures
that dr wolinski just mentioned and b
get as many people vaccinated as quickly
as we possibly can
that's the best defense against the
evolution
of variance i'll stop there and back to
you andy
thank you doctor all right why don't we
go why don't we go to questions
all right thank you guys um i'm not
seeing any hands raised but if you could
raise your hand we can go ahead and
start
q a
all right first we'll go to caitlin
collins at cnn
hi so i have two questions
one about the variance i know that
before we've gone over them and we've
said that the
the latest numbers have been a couple
hundred cases but we also know that you
know we're pretty behind on
sequencing and working to ramp that up
so what number do we think is
actually out there and how much higher
do you think it could be than
the numbers that we've actually
identified positively so far
and then my second question is about a
comment that transportation secretary
pete putin judge made saying that they
are considering
requiring testing for domestic flights
what would the benefits of that be given
we know
just how much transmission there is in
the us right now and the data on
how much it spreads on flights when
everyone is wearing a mask or the lack
of i guess would there be benefits to
that actually happening
so maybe first why don't i turn to dr
walensky to talk about our
ongoing efforts at surveillance and
increasing
our knowledge and maybe a little bit
about what the current state of
knowledge
we think might be with regard to these
variances
a doctor great thank you and thank you
for the question
what i can say is um we're learning more
about the number of variants and the
number of variants that you're hearing
increase is very much at least in part
due to the fact that we're doing a lot
more sequencing of these variants
so over the last three weeks or so we've
increased our
sequencing about tenfold so as we look
more we're certainly going
anticipate we might find more over the
next several weeks we are hoping we are
planning actually
to not only get uh collab have
collaboration with the um
state labs from every state so we make
sure we're sampling from every state but
also from with collaborations from
commercial labs as well as academic labs
so we anticipate that we're probably
going to be sequencing
up to three or four more than we're
already sequencing and i think once we
have
more sequencing that's happening um
we'll have a better idea as to how many
variants there are and what proportion
um are out there
do we have a ballpark estimate of how
much higher it is than what we actually
know right now because i
i think the understanding is that it's a
lot higher than what we know is that
correct
um i would be reluctant to give you an
estimate right now based on our current
data but i'd be happy to get back with
you on that one
let me take your second question uh i
haven't heard
uh secretary budejig's comment but i
would say
as and dr wolinski may want to comment
is that with regard to domestic travel i
think in the words of
dr wolinski and cdc now is not the time
to be traveling
if at all possible um and so dr wolinski
do you want to say a word about
traveling and safety measures with
regard to travel
yeah what i would add is um
[Music]
the more screening that we're doing in
places where people are gathering
i think the more asymptomatic disease we
will be detecting
um and certainly there's a lot of um
there's more gathering that happens in
airports and so the
you know to the extent that we have
available tests to be able to do
testing first and foremost i would
really encourage people to not
travel but if we are traveling this
would be yet another mitigation measure
to try and decrease the spread
thank you let's go to the next question
next we'll go to brian cameron bulwark
thank you very much uh and thanks for
taking the question this question is for
dr
fauci um dr fauci uh we are talking
about the mutant varieties of this
virus and we are stressing that we need
to get as many
um vaccinated as possible now when i
speak to
scientists they tell us that eventually
that uh viruses like this tend to mutate
to a
a less harmful or a less virulent strain
is there any data or scientific concerns
that this particular virus
is mutating into a more virulent strain
or a more dangerous strain and it is
more dangerous as it mutates
and then i have okay well the answer to
your question is
right now we certainly don't have any
data to indicate that
it is mutating into a less virulent
strain
the initial data that came out from the
uk
about it having a degree of increased
virulence
that is still i think uh something i
wouldn't say that's questionable but i
think that needs to be confirmed
but thus far no evidence that it is less
virulent sometimes when viruses mutate
to
spread more efficiently they become less
virulent but we do not
have any data to indicate that that is
in fact
happening with saw's kobe 2. and then
the follow-up to that question is
if it is becoming or or if your concern
is that it is more virulent
how long will the efficacy of the
current vaccines
under this structure have you been able
to gain that out to determine when
that efficacy will uh will be dampened
or will lessen
well i think that's obviously going to
take an observation over a longer period
of time
we've got to really be careful because
there are two things that are going on
right now
a virus is transmissible and it's
virulent and the degree of
transmissibility and the degree of
virulence
can actually overlap and result because
you've heard us say
on our briefings that a virus that has a
greater degree of transmissibility will
be making more people sick
the more people that get sick the more
people that will be hospitalized
and the more people that are
hospitalized you'll likely get more
deaths
but on a one-to-one basis whether or not
it is truly more virulent
right now we don't have any indication
that that's the case here
and we'll just have to continue to
observe which we do
you know the vaccine trials they ended
and came up with a
efficacy of 94 to 95 but the trials go
on for two years so we'll learn a lot
more over the next couple of years
so they're still following up on this
both from the study as well as
being reported to the fda so if there's
any information in that regard
it will become available to us as the
months and year goes by
thank you brian hey dr fauci just just
to clarify something
if you if you wouldn't mind um
very fair question from brian
speculating about the future
but uh maybe you can emphasize what we
know today
about the efficacy and safety of the
viruses
relative to what the threats we face
today well right now
what we're seeing now in our country is
still a dominant original wild-type
virus of which the vaccines
are highly efficacious 94 to 95 percent
the immediate concern that we have is
that
the fact that we have the 117 in
certainly a considerable number of
states reported with a number of people
that modeling would tell us andy that it
could become dominant by the end of
march
that's the sobering news the encouraging
news
is that the vaccines that we're
currently distributing right now
are quite effective against that
particular variant
less so against the you the against the
south african the 3-5-1
but hopefully we will get the virus
under much better control
by the time there's any indication that
that that that might become
dominant so again it gets back andy to
vaccinating as many people as you
possibly can
in implementing the public health
measures great
thank you okay next question please
next we'll go to sharon lafferner at new
york times
hi thank you for taking my question um i
have
actually two questions the first is um
statistical for
andy you told us um how many doses were
administered in the
long-term care program uh what's the
total number of doses that were set
aside for that program
in other words what's the denominator
and then secondly
on on the new pharmacy program is there
going to be a
separate registration system for that
uh and if so what does that mean for all
the people
who had already signed up at their local
health departments and have been waiting
in line do they start over
is there going to be some kind of
integration between these different
systems now
thank you for the question i thought i
was off the hook when you said it was
statistical i was
quite confident was going to go to one
of the experts
relative to the long-term care program
there are a lot of numbers moving around
and so i think it's important to
emphasize um what i what i
talked about earlier which is that we've
administered 4.8 million doses
to more than 3.7 million people
and what we don't have for you today is
a breakdown of how many
doses are first and second doses
likewise what percentage of the
population in nursing homes or long-term
care facilities
are fully vaccinated so i want to make
sure i'm sticking as precisely as
possible
to what the uh cdc study said and
and i would invite dr wolinski when i'm
finished if there are any
additions or corrections to that to add
them but it's important that that i
think things are phrased that way we do
know
that that for the centers that have
vaccination clinics
the median number of people and this was
as of
sometime in the end of january the
median number of of uh residents that
were vaccinated was 80
so that gives you i think a decent
approximation in terms of pharmacies
many of the pharmacies do have their own
registration systems
in place and so those are the
registration systems that i think
they will likely continue to use in the
near term
i think your question about dealing with
separate registration systems
is a good one for example people may
want to
try to understand more about how they
can
find a place where they can get
vaccinated and i think particularly is
there's more supply
that's going to be important and i have
nothing to announce today other than the
that we are looking very uh closely
at that question and how we might be
able to help people
should we go to the next question mr
wrote kristen welker at nbc
hi everyone thank you first
question is can you give us your
assessment of some of the states that
have begun to relax
their protocols for example iowa among
those
who has reversed some of the indoor
requirements
in terms of masking and public social
distancing
and also given that a number of schools
all across the country
are discussing how they are going to
reopen there is an
urgency to that matter i know that you
said that the cdc's guidelines for
school reopenings would be coming soon
when can people expect to see that and
have you gotten to a place where you can
give us any indication about
whether you think t-shirts should be
vaccinated before schools reopen
great well i think both of those are
probably going ahead uh for you dr
wolinski but let me let's do the
first one um is your comment on
states or local jurisdictions that may
be relaxing
some of the public health standards that
the cdc has been recommending
so maybe i'll just start and say um
given that we're still at over a hundred
thousand cases a day
i would discourage any such activity um
and i would say that we are still
in a in the first hundred days where we
wanted certainly everybody masked for
the first hundred days i think
we we have yet to control this pandemic
we still have this emerging threat of
variance
and i would just simply discourage any
of those activities we really need to
keep
all of the mitigation measures at play
here if we're really going to
to get control of this pandemic
and in that regard as we move towards
and think about schools
what we know mostly about schools in
terms of the data
are that most infections come
into the schools through the community
the data from schools suggests that
there's very little transmission that is
happening within the schools
especially when there's masking and
distancing occurring and that when there
are transmissions in the schools it is
because they've brought been brought in
from the community
and because they are breaches and
masking and distancing so
if we want to get our schools open and
our schools open safely and well
the best way to do that is to decrease
the community spread
so i would say we need to keep up our
social distancing and our masking and
all of our other mitigation measures
our cdc guidance on school reopening
will be coming
in the days ahead and um i look forward
to
thinking through those with everybody
great thank you
uh do we have a next question last
question we'll go to isaac stanley
becker at
washington post thanks for taking my
question uh it follows up on
kristin's first question so in light of
the fact that this is the recommendation
of the cdc can you say a little bit more
about what the administration is doing
to communicate this guidance and these
instructions
to governors and other officials out in
the country discouraging them from
taking some of these steps or is
ultimately is this largely
a state and local matter where the
administration's power is limited
so i just wanted to confirm uh not that
the question was asked that long ago
but your question that you're talking
about um
conversations with governors
about steps that they're those that are
taking steps
to relax mitigation standards is that is
that your question
that's right just if you could say a
little bit more about what the
administration is doing to provide
counsel and instructions
on issues like mass mandates uh dining
restrictions
to you know especially in light of the
spread of these variants
well all across government we talk to
the states uh
incredibly frequently so maybe we'll go
around and see dr lenski if there's
anything you want to add to your
previous answer
i will just say i think our stand on
this is is pretty well
established we i attend a weekly
governor's call at least and i know that
and i've been
in touch one-on-one with numerous
governors already so i'm doing my best
and i'm happy to be doing more to
encourage the states to decrease their
community spread
so that we can um decrease the threat of
these variants decreased our
hospitalizations and and get this
pandemic under control
and the only thing i'll add to that is
that
um you know we understand the pressure
the government the governors are under
we are taking a collaborative approach
as much as possible
sharing with them the data helping them
understand as we've covered on this call
why we're in such a critical period
to combating the virus and
hope to continue to work to persuade and
partner with
states and localities um to continue to
follow sensible public health measures
um until such time as we're in a
situation where the case rates
are down uh are down lower we think
that's wise
um we we think that the the voice of the
cdc
is preeminent here they look at all the
data
uh they're clear in communicating with
the public and we'll continue to have
those conversations
um with the states um but i won't i
won't go into any of the specific
one-on-one conversations that we have
with states
uh because i think that might be
counterproductive uh i want to thank you
for all for attending our briefing i
think we
hit the half hour mark pretty precisely
we look forward to a productive week
collectively and to talking with you all
again on wednesday
you